what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
7 preview video now that episode 4 is
over I want to take a quick peek at the
upcoming episode and I think this next
episode is going to be a bit of a
game-changer for this season there
probably won't be any major battles or
anything like that but all the chess
pieces on the border about the shift as
we build up to the finale of this season
and I will be talking about some minor
spoilers in this video so make sure you
proceed with caution if you do not want
to be spoiled on anything we have seen
many exciting things this season so far
but there is one major event that has
yet to take place
episode 5 is going to set everything in
motion for the final epic battle in this
season and we got a glimpse of that into
season 7 trailers a few months ago Jon
Snow will be leading a group of men
beyond the wall where they will
eventually encounter the army of the
Dead and this is going to eventually
turn into a monumental Royal Rumble
beyond the wall Jon Snow has spent two
whole episodes on Dragonstone
but in episode 5 he will begin to form
his Suicide Squad that he takes with him
up north but before John leaves
Dragonstone something is going to happen
that most of us have been dying to see
for a very long time Jon Snow will have
his first face-to-face interaction with
Daenerys Targaryen dragon and I'm not
just talking about a flyover it's going
to be much more than that
this was also teased in the trailer
months ago as well when Daenerys
Targaryen arrives back on Dragonstone
after her intense battle with the
Lannisters she's going to land on the
beach with drogon and they're going to
come up to where Jon Snow is standing if
you look at this scene from the trailer
you can see a close-up of drug on what
Daenerys on is back and if you look
behind them you can see the castle on
Dragonstone Daenerys is going to
approach John with their dragon but John
isn't going to be as scared as Daenerys
would expect in fact we should see a
little bit of a bond between John and
Rogan and this will probably confuse the
Narus and possibly even make her a
little bit jealous but the most
important thing is this will further
confirm that Jon Snow doesn't just have
stark blood in his veins but he also has
Targaryen blood in his veins as well the
blood of the dragon and this will
probably cause the internet to break
everyone is going to be wondering will
Jon Snow aka John Stark aka Joe
targaryen ever ride a dragon himself
well we could end up seeing something
like that in season eight if the knight
king does kill one of Danny's dragons
and mounted for himself we could
potentially see an epic battle of the
Dragons in the sky with the knight King
on one dragon and John and Daenerys on
their own dragons and that would be
crazy as hell if that happened but
before I go too far down that road I'm
going to wait and talk about that later
when and if the night King actually gets
the damn thing first
but in Episode five there are going to
be a bunch of other cool moments too
that I want to talk about there is
another thing that everyone has been
wondering for years and that is where
the [ __ ] has Gendry been we haven't seen
Gendry since season three when Davos set
him free from the cells on Dragonstone
for all we know he has been rowing that
damn boat this entire time is it
possible that Gendry became the Westeros
version of Tom Hanks in castaway
has he been hiding in one of these caves
on Dragonstone this entire time I hope
he hasn't started calling his bow head
helmet Wilson I'm just kidding though
but episode 5 will be the episode Gendry
makes his return
it looks like Gendry was in the trailer
with the other 12 companions beyond the
wall
most people have speculated this is
Gendry standing in the circle of men
holding a Warhammer some people have
even said this is Robert Baratheon's
Warhammer that he has but I actually
disagree I think if Gentry does have a
Warhammer I think he made it himself now
that he knows he is Robert Baratheon's
bastard son thanks to Melisandre ginjury
has probably been in King's Landing this
entire time most likely under an
anonymous name being a blacksmith is one
of the only things he is really good at
so that's most likely what he went back
to doing in order to feed himself
Davos told him as long as the gold
cloaks don't know what he looks like
then he really has nothing to worry
about because they've been looking for
Davos for years
so if Gendry started using a different
name he could probably move around
King's Landing freely John will be
leaving dragon stone in episode 5 to
head towards eastwatch-by-the-sea right
where he told tormund ago so Gendry has
to show up in the next episode to go up
north with John and Davos because John
will be taking injury along with him and
speaking of eastwatch-by-the-sea you
know who else we haven't seen in a long
time
we haven't seen the hound and the
Brotherhood without banners since the
very first episode of this season these
men will also be accompanying Joe
sno beyond the wall which we also saw in
the trailers to John is going to have
one hell of a crew with him when he runs
into the army of the Dead
since the hound saw the vision and the
flames back in the first episode they
should be at eastwatch-by-the-sea
already right where the wall meets the
ice John snow will be heading there to
meet up what torment and the Brotherhood
to go out beyond the wall in search of
the army of the Dead like I said earlier
in this video there will be a lot of
characters moving around on this episode
and what that being said there is
another character on the move right now
I thought he might actually show up an
episode four but since he didn't that I
know he's going to show up an episode 5
and that is Sir Jorah Mormont he is now
a free man that no longer has greyscale
so he's going to be hauling ass to get
back to his Khaleesi I imagine he's
going to arrive while Daenerys is there
and they should have a very warm reunion
together Daenerys was in tears when
Jorah broke the news to her that he had
this deadly disease but she demanded
that he go get himself cured then come
back to her so he could be by her side
while she takes over Westeros and I am
looking forward to Jon and Jorah Mormont
finally meeting as well especially since
jon is carrying house Mormont former
Valyrian steel sword the bear is no
longer on the sword but Jorah should
still recognize it and I'm expecting
John to tell Jorah how close of a
relationship he had with his father and
how loyal Lyanna Mormont has been for
House Stark I think Jon can help repair
George reputation with his own family if
George does go beyond the wall with Jon
and help him on this dangerous mission
that should be enough for leona to
potentially accept him back into the
family I have always said Jon will end
up offering Longclaw back to the Mormons
but it's hard to say if either one of
them would ever accept it once Samwell
Tarly gets back up north with hearts
Bane there will be a Valyrian steel
sword up for grabs for someone else to
use but that's assuming Sam doesn't use
it himself the last time we saw Sam he
was with Jorah Mormont during his last
checkup when they learned he was
completely cured of greyscale Sam could
be another thing that helps form that
bond between Jon and Jorah Mormont the
next time we see Sam and Gilly we could
possibly learn about another explosive
discovery that they have made after
Jorah was discharged from the Citadel
Sam was given the task of making copies
of all the old manuscripts and documents
that were lying around and rotting away
I think there will be something in those
old documents that will change
everything and compel Sam and Gilly to
the citadel and take their asses back
north before the long night actually
starts to set in there is really only a
few things I think Sam and Gilly can
potentially discover that is a
game-changer right now or at least a few
things that actually makes sense to the
direction that the story is going in
they may learn some more about the long
night and how to defeat the white
walkers they could even learn something
about making Valyrian steel or even
something that further proves the
legitimacy of Jon Snow's Targaryen words
proven that he has the blood of a dragon
as well it's going to be something big
that motivates Sam enough to leave the
Citadel and go and reunite with John
again because I do not think Sam is
going to stay at the Citadel for as long
as it takes to become a maester by the
end of this season the band of brothers
will start to unite to form this super
group of characters that are going to
take on the army of the Dead together
whether that be on the battlefield or
done behind the scenes with their minds
either way all of the best and smartest
characters that we are familiar with
will all start to come together with
only a few episodes left before all hell
breaks loose as we wind down to the end
of the season things should start to
begin to get more and more interesting
and exciting while everyone prepares for
the storm that the night king is about
to bring and I cannot wait to see the
death and destruction that's about to
take place
episode 5 might not be action-packed but
I still think it should be a very solid
episode Daenerys is going to return
after a deadly battle with the
Lannisters and when she touches down on
Dragonstone we will see Jon Snow and
Rogan interact with each other
the bond between John and the Dragons
will have officially begun
and hit that like button if you are R +
L equals J believer because I know I am
also we may or may not touch base with
the Hound and the Brotherhood again as
they arrive at eastwatch-by-the-sea to
prepare to follow the vision that the
Hound saw in the flames
Gendry will make his return and Jorah
Mormont will make his return as well Sam
and Gilly may discover something
incredible in those old as dusty
documents the archmaester as Sam to make
copies of personally I am really looking
forward to this episode seeing all these
characters uniting to go beyond the wall
to fight the common enemy is going to be
a lot of fun I really enjoy watching all
these characters individually but seeing
them all together and the same scene is
just spoiling me so thank you so much
Game of Thrones thank you so much HBO
I have been so anxious to see this
battle beyond the wall with all these
amazing characters coming together and
this is only going to be a taste of
what's to come because once the dead
march past a wall then we're going to
need every single character to come
together if they ever want to stop them
whether you believe in this [ __ ] or not
you must help or you will die
comment down below and let me know what
are some of the things you are looking
forward to the most in the upcoming
episode the blood of the Dragon there is
going to be so much moving around and
this one I am really just looking
forward to seeing some characters share
some scenes together that have never met
before that should be interesting to see
how they form relationships with one
another but let me know what you want to
see the most I want to thank everyone
for stopping by to check out this quick
preview of episode 5 I will be uploading
my full breakdown of episode 4 tomorrow
then I will upload my breakdown of the
preview trailer for episode 5 on Tuesday
I hope you all come back to check those
out as well and I want to give a shout
out to Alex to who was nice enough to
make me some banner art from my Twitter
account I really appreciate you doing
that Alex and I want to thank all my
patreon supporters to the support I have
been receiving from everyone watching
and listening to this video right now
has been absolutely incredible I never
could have imagined that whatever come
close to having 100,000 subscribers just
saying that number and looking at that
number on the screen blows my mind and I
never could have achieved that without
all of you wonderful people coming back
day after day to discuss this story and
show that we all love so much thank you
everyone I will see you down in the
comment section bye
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]